Markiplier: Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to four- the days and the...escaping of the don't do!
Mmm don't!
Uh, hi guys.
[P L B B B H H]
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Don't Escape 4.
We've got spiders that are so excited to eat my face off
they are shooting cobwebs out of their buttholes
into the sky
in celebration of my future death.
But we're not gonna give em the cha-a-ance!
[SMACK]
Stoopid!
I'm not gonna give 'em the chaaance!
So we're gonna go over into the wasteland, and
Now that we know what we're gonna do,
now we can get through this
in so much better fashion!
I can kinda like...
I can kinda get things done quickly
Like, I can make this work!
You know what I mean? I can make it work
I, I-- I know what I'm doing
Oh man I can't-- I can't lift as much
Thi-- this version of myself isn't as lifty as the other one was, so
Wubumbus!
and wublumbus
Alright, so now I want-- I know it wants me to drop this into the wasteland
This is gonna be so cool
'Cause now, like there's gotta be a way to save everybody
And if I can save everybody
Then I can have everyone there, and there can be a way to make sure that the
That, the, the, the--
The problem was there was there was something that we couldn't pick the desti--
I should've written it down
Alright, okay, I don't remember exactly what it was
But there was something
That was like you-- you couldn't pick the destination of where you go
So it defaulted to emergency mode
And then you had to, uh, you had to basically be back in your own body
But with this we can
LLLLLaunch ourselves
*launches self*
Off into another body where this ain't gonna happen
And that way we don't have to make mistakes
Well this place looks promising
Oh yea it do
Oh yea it do-- I don't have a map yet
So let's just go for this
We know what we need to do here
Or at least generally I know what I need to do here.
Alright, a door
It's locked
Why is it locked?
Who knows
I forget if the back door's open
Yeah, the water sprayer
Is-- is the water sprayer   ever used?
I honestly have no idea
He made a joke about it at the end of the game, but
You know, I dunno
Okay there's a short pipe here
Some kinda thing there
I should find a way to get into that house before I start fiddling with things in--
Hey wait, there's only one inlet
*gasp*
Things are gonna be slightly different!
Oh!
Things are gonna be s--
Ohhh yeah!
[Mark laughing]
WuBUMski!
[glass shatters]
Alright, get in there!
Oh yeah, yeah crash it all up
Oh hell yeah
Oh yeah
Photo, old lady...
I don't know if anything'd be different
Or if it's actually important that anything's different at all
Um
Okay we gotta take that, definitely
We gotta fix it, eventually
I'm not worried about it right now but we will eventually fix it
Go upstairs...
We just need to grab everything that's available for now
'Cause I'm gonna kinda like hyperspeed through this
Uh, with not much in the way
But these spiders are gonna be the biggest problem
There was a paper clip holding something together
The documents [trails off]
Wait, I got a paper clip?
Whaaa?!!
I don't even remember getting a paper clip before
(Thought realize now) Things are slightly DiF-FeRenT
(Getting excited) I love it!
I LOVE IT!
Ok I can put the documents away
'Cause I'm pretty sure that just gotta be like
For tin...tind-- KinGling... TinDling... TinDerling!
If I need, aah, to make that happen
Okay, so I can probably pick a lock with that or something of that nature
Ohh, this is so cool
It's locked! I wonder why?
Now I don't have to be paranoid about locking and unlocking again
Because that'd just be stupid
Okay, so now I'm gonna go
Mm...East first
I know the gas station, I know all that jazz
What about over here? I remember this place
I remember it
Oh I re--
EUUUUUGHH
UUUGHHOAHH
Oh yeah, okay, spider webs, okay
You're telling me THAT
Nuh uh, that ain't--
MMMMMMMMM NOPE
That's--
[disgusted noises]
Ewww....
Alright
So that's a bite mark that I probably need to remember
That's probably important
Yeah, let's inspect the car
Car's busted, and the ignition coil, getting it out won't be easy
Ah, adjustable wrench
Well hey, there you go
Ugh, guh [disgusted noises]
Small leaflet tucked in between the ripped clothes
[Mark reads note in an unspecified southern accent]
Alright
Yeah
uhOOOH
It's ectoplasm!
Hey, it's covered in it, it's-it's a ghost was in here!
Uh, I need a crowbar or s--
Ooh wait, hang on
Try to pick the lock? Uh, yes please!
[nervous laughter] Everything's different
Things are--
Bear traps? For spiders??
More like spider traps
HO HO HO HO HO HO HO HO
Alright, whadda we got in there?
Oh hell yeah, B...
Oh god, what's with all the Bs?
Alright whatever I guess I'm gonna have a lot of Bs
I'm guessing I need a specific type for the spiders
Yeah probably
It's locked, how about the paper clip?
Ah yeah
Yerpis
Oh, yeah duct tape!
Let's put duct tape on the handle
Never mind, I need a new handle
I forgot
Alright whatever, you know, I tried
It's all good
Alright, nothing there
And a note, here we go
[Mark reads the note]
Okay
So this one had 2 big bites and 4 small bites
I think it's B-36 is what I'm gonna need
I should've waited until I actually saw that before that
But how would I have known that?
It's not like I've been in the future or anything
[goofy laugh]
HUEH
Let's see, yeah, take it out
I've removed the ignition coil
Okay, good
That's all we're gonna need
Lemme double check the bite just in case
2 big and then 4 on the outside
So okay, so we're gonna go to the bridge first
We're gonna grab this
TUNK
We're gonna combine this with this
With the knowledge of forethought!
I...
...am a genius (sure)
I think it'd be worth it to go back home at this point
And drop some stuff off
I need the nails, that's right
I need the nails
[gasp]
I'm so smart
I'm so smart!
Okay, put the bear traps away
Put the insect repellent away
I only need B-36 anyway
Which is right here
Put the rest over there
Useless
[sarcasm]
Water spur, very useful
Obviously incredibly useful
By the way, we're gonna be flying through this
I've got tons of time
On the first day, I have all the time in the world
Nails
Naaails
Naaaaails
Naaaaaaaaails
Alright let's go up in here
Let's put the ignition coil
UUUUUWWWHHHHH
I put it away!
[sound of Mark's mind melting]
Now we got it
Now we're going for it
Now we're getting it
Now we're going
Now we're going strong
Now we're going strong and hot
Now we're going strong and hot and heavy
Okay well, the car could be started I guess
But it doesn't look very good
Obviously a wheel's missing
The ignition coil's busted
And it has no fuel
Alright, well, ignition coil
Bada bing, bada boom
Ha-Booski!
Alight I've installed this part
Good,
Good, great,
Good, great, gotcha
Alright, now we can get outta here
We need to get some fuel and a wheel
I can also
Go ahead and basically
Make one bridge for me to...
Ooooh, that's a lot of time
That's fine, yeah
It'll save time on travel
So let's just go ahead and go road West
'Cause that's enough to get me across
And then I've got 3 nails left to make the barricade
WHAT THE FUCK?!
These goddamn spiders!
What, are they here already?!
This is disgusting!
What, are there just
Like hundreds of them walking and just
[fart noises]
They fart out all this everywhere?!
What is the point?!
There's nothing to be gleaned
WHEEEY!
[stunned silence]
ALRIGHT
WELP
Ahahum!
Oohoohooh
Uhh
Beh
Blahum!
Um, okay, alright that's
That's new
Um
Imma whack you with a wrench
It hasn't noticed me yet, I'd rather keep it that way
I don't wanna go near that spider
Fuck!
Okay, I guess
Yeah, you know what, you right
Oh, it's too heavy, I have to put something down first, do I?
Oh okay, I'll put down...
[spooky music]
Uhh, let's see...the, uh
I don't like that sound
[spooky music]
I don't like the change in music
I don't like that at all
I'll put down th-th-the super sprayer
Who needs it?
Put you down
Is that light enough?
No?
Alright
Let's put down the uh...
Wrench, 'cause I need it here anyway
To get the gas
So let's just do that
It's too heavy, where's-- 9?!
9 pounds you say?
Well we'll put the short pipe down as well
Alright, let's take this
'Cause I wanna get it all in one go
Alright, well
A rock!
Is that what that rock's for?
Are you telling me...
...the rock's for throwing at a spidey?!
I bet it is, I bet it is!
I gotta be careful though because otherwise I'm gonna lose my stuff
Okay
Metal bars,
Metal bars, metal bars,
Metal bars, metal bars, metal bars
I can leave the nails here as well because those are for the metal bars
Okay, so I think that's gotta be it
I can like, distract the spider with the small rock
I-- it all makes sense!
It all makes soonse!
Okay, we're gonna...
Well, let me get my stuff first
Before I do any of that shit
Lemme get this
Lemme get the plastic wrap too
Just in case
'Cause you never know
Alright, I don't think that was too heavy, nah it was not
Let's throw the rock over here
I don't wanna get--
Oh, come on!
Stop being such a byuuuetch
Throw the rock at the spider!
Okay, there's gotta be a way to distract it
It's gotta be something to do with throwing the rock
Oh, come on!
That makes...
[plates shatter]
WHEEEEEEEEEEEEEEY!
Alright, I'm gonna fuckin' shoot you
Okay, we're good, we're all good
Grab the cash
Grab the cash!
Trinket stand, there's a lighter
Charcoal, I don't think I can carry that
Newspaper stand
"Lunar Explosion"
We all know about that!
Should I shoot this guy?
[gasp]
Ooh, ooh, ooh!
Gonna shoot you!
D-- OH FUCK
BANG!
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHH
WHEEEEEY!
HEHEHEHEH!
Alright, well
I'm down a bullet
But you know that..I think all worth it
Corpse
"This man is dead"
"Covered by webs and partially eaten"
I don't wanna touch him
What? You think, uh, that spider's better than you?
You're gonna let that spider touch that man, but not you?
You stupid fool
Thank you, rock
You really did a good...
You really...
You really did a good.
You did a great, actually
You did a great.
Let's get some gas up in this ass
Aahhh, wrench
I know what to do now
I know all of what to do
I know so much of what to do
Oh yeah, it's too--
FUUUCK
That's fine, uh, I guess I can drop the wraps for now
I don't think I need them
I don't think, anyway
I could drop the rock, too...
I think that'd be, it's--
I think it's just fine
I don't need those to survive tonight
I think if anything needs metal bars
It's giant spiders
They're gonna definitely need the metal bars
So I can leave those there
Lemme save just in case
Okay, so we're gonna go back
I need to put the metal bars on the window
That's number 1
Let's go ahead and put this on the window here
'Cause I knoooow we're gonna do this
Yeah, ya ya
Put this one right there
Yeah, yeah
Now I'm using my time more efficiently
Oh, I don't have the other one yet
Yo, oh man, I'm flying with this
I am flying!
And now I know you gotta put the bear traps on the outside
That's what's important about that
Alright, all the windows have been barred
And now I'm gonna bring this out
And this out
Because I need to go to the backyard
To the barn here
I need to eventually fix this shit
[Mark noises]
Put-a the duct-a tape-a on-a the that
Put the, uh, it's definitely B-36
Yep, B-36, okay
Only one needs there
Okay, emergency power
Uh, we're going to the water pump
We're gonna start it
Oh yeah
Ohhh
That's right, I need fuel for this!
Well good thing I didn't put it in the truck already
Because I'm not gonna get the truck started now
There we go
Okay, so the water pump's ready
Oh wait I know how to do this now
Let's do overnight spray mist
Oinkus boinkus boinkus boinkus
Heheheheh!
Now I know the secret to it
Okay, efficiency's at maximum
That's all good to go
Uhh
Found an abandoned house
Hunting rifle, some bullets, not a perfect weapon
Probably will help
I installed iron bars
Scheduled the water sprinklers to put out the wall of mist
"Will this be enough?"
No! Of course not, you idiot!
I might still have time to go get some gas
Right now
I think I still have time
I think I do, yeah I- I do, I do, I definitely do
Okay, let's go get some gas
Because there is time
Because I built that rooooad
Like a smartieee
And I can get these things
Yeah, you never know when you're going to need a plastic and a rock!
Aaand a badaboski
Saving tiiiiiime for later
Cuz' now I don't have to gas it up
Now I just bring back the wheel
And that's going to save me on another day
My efficiency is gonna pay off in dividends!
Pour that in there
Fuel the car
The wheel's still missing but that's all set and ready to go
This is ready to go
Let's go ahead and close the door here and then lock it
Then let's go ahead- oh wait I'm- BEAR TRAPS
That's right
So we need to put bear traps-
NO NO NO NO NO NO,
You silly bitch
Bear trap, bear trap
Put one in front and one in back
Sound like to me yes yes.
so lets go into here lets close the door, lets lock her up.
And i think... thats all she wrote for this
i think
if i done my math correctly there's nothing else to do.
can I prove my chances somehow?
(In a voice what sounds like hes choking) I dOn'T Think so.
i put the poison out for the right spider there's no repelling device.
I've got everything i need
yea, we're good to go. yea let's do this, let's go for it.
and a hunting rifle.
(Reading) Alright "The evening sky darkened as a pack of huge spiders followed your scent..."
"You found a hiding place in an abandoned farmhouse.."
"An automated sprinkler system kicked in as the pack was getting near."
"Despite being old and faulty, the sprinklers worked perfectly, fully covering the air above the fields with a dense mist. The spiders were not afraid of water at all..."
"However, there was a strong repellent mixed with the water. It scared off 6 spiders."
"You decided to set up some traps outside the house..."
"You placed two traps outside your hideout. Two of the spiders walked right into them."
"The front door was closed, keeping away all of the spiders that would have entered through it."
"The back door was closed, keeping away all of the spiders that would have entered through it."
"The window on the ground floor was reinforced with metal bars. The bars were nailed to the frame."
"Out of 4 spiders that tried to enter the house through that window, 4 were stopped."
"The window on the upper floor was reinforced with metal bars."